ANJALI KUMAR: It's Lunch Time
at Google with Anjali Kumar.
Today our guest is
Garance Dore.
GARANCE DORE: I like how
say Garance Dore.
ANJALI KUMAR: Is that right?
GARANCE DORE: In French it's
like Garance Dore.
ANJALI KUMAR: Isn't
that what I said?
Garance Dore.
GARANCE DORE: Perfect.
ANJALI KUMAR: That's
pretty good, right?
GARANCE DORE: Very good.
ANJALI KUMAR: I speak
really good French.
We can do part of the
interview in French
later if you want.
GARANCE DORE: OK, yeah.
ANJALI KUMAR: Because I'm
basically fluent.
GARANCE DORE: [SPEAKING FRENCH]
ANJALI KUMAR: I brought
you lunch.
I brought us lunch.
GARANCE DORE: OK.
ANJALI KUMAR: I got
myself a sandwich.
And I got you some water.
GARANCE DORE: That's exactly
what I need right now.
Thank you.
You know Fashion Week is
around the corner.
ANJALI KUMAR: I know.
I got lemon, too.
GARANCE DORE: Oh my
god, even better.
Two calories?
Oh my god.
ANJALI KUMAR: The whole
lemon has 12.
So I figured this much,
maybe one and a half?
You've been writing this
beloved fashion and
illustration blog since 2006.
GARANCE DORE: Yes.
ANJALI KUMAR: Can tell us
a little bit about the
evolution, and how you started,
and the evolution to
what it is now?
GARANCE DORE: Of course.
The serious way?
ANJALI KUMAR: Sure,
however you roll.
GARANCE DORE: The blog started
because I was an illustrator.
I was like you.
I was at my office, all
day at my desk.
What a life.
ANJALI KUMAR: Pardon
my French.
GARANCE DORE: Yes,
pardon my French.
Sucks.
ANJALI KUMAR: Who is the most
active commenter on your blog?
Do you have like one guy that's
always like, great
picture, nice legs?
GARANCE DORE: There is people
who comment every day.
I can't describe it.
Like, there is so many.
I receive emails.
People name their
kids Garance.
ANJALI KUMAR: Do you think
they know where you live?
GARANCE DORE: If they look at
the blog, like very, if they
want to know where I
live, it's not that
difficult to find.
You can get so many information
on people.
ANJALI KUMAR: How do they do
that, all that information
that's available?
GARANCE DORE: Right.
ANJALI KUMAR: Such a problem.
So "Pardon My French" is
your newest endeavor.
Do you know what pardon my
French means in English?
GARANCE DORE: Yes, of course.
ANJALI KUMAR: What
does it mean?
GARANCE DORE: It means,
if I say merde, I can
say pardon my French.
It means--
ANJALI KUMAR: So do you walk
around just like, [BLEEP]
this [BLEEP], pardon
my French?
I mean, this fashion [BLEEP]
[BLEEP]
and I [BLEEP].
And I hate this [BLEEP].
GARANCE DORE: Yeah.
ANJALI KUMAR: Stuff like that?
That's what you guys
go around saying?
You're like, oh, pardon
my French.
GARANCE DORE: Exactly.
So I try to not swear too
much on the videos.
ANJALI KUMAR: Did I
just offend you?
GARANCE DORE: Well
then that's good.
It's your video.
We can have fun.
[BLEEP]
you.
ANJALI KUMAR: [BLEEP]
GARANCE DORE: [BLEEP]
ANJALI KUMAR: So I want to
switch directions a little
bit, and talk about
signature style.
Like the Anna Wintour,
she's got the bob.
GARANCE DORE: Right.
ANJALI KUMAR: Like there's
people who have that one
defining characteristic.
So I've been working
on something.
And I'm hoping you
can help me.
Just tell me what you think.
And maybe help me brand it.
So can I just show you?
So just give me a minute, and
I'll just be right back.
OK, so this is what
I'm thinking.
Can you see me?
GARANCE DORE: That's why
I say don't try to
have a signature style.
If it comes to you, it does.
Just let it happen.
ANJALI KUMAR: This
hat came to me.
It spoke to me in the store.
GARANCE DORE: Do you really
want a signature style?
Do you want to be
Clint Eastwood?
Anna Wintour?
ANJALI KUMAR: Who doesn't?
I feel like it gives me
a little ethnic flare.
GARANCE DORE: It gives
you some edge.
Yeah.
ANJALI KUMAR: Don't you think?
Stripes, and they go in,
so they're slimming.
GARANCE DORE: No it's really--
ANJALI KUMAR: Slimming.
GARANCE DORE: You look
like a parachute.
It's not very slimming.
ANJALI KUMAR: Like
a parachute?
GARANCE DORE: You know,
when the, you know?
You're totally YOLO.
ANJALI KUMAR: What
does that mean?
GARANCE DORE: Like you
only live once.
Let's do everything.
ANJALI KUMAR: YOLO?
GARANCE DORE: You
don't know that?
ANJALI KUMAR: I never
heard that before.
No.
GARANCE DORE: Oh, come on.
ANJALI KUMAR: That's
not a thing.
I work at Google.
It's not a thing.
I don't know.
I'm getting old, though.
So it might be a thing.
GARANCE DORE: Yes.
It's a big thing.
ANJALI KUMAR: It's a thing?
GARANCE DORE: Yeah, and
you're totally that.
ANJALI KUMAR: Wait, so what
are you going to call my
signature style with
the poncho?
Skydiving chic.
GARANCE DORE: Right, exactly.
Para chic.
ANJALI KUMAR: Para chic.
YOLO para chic.
GARANCE DORE: Yeah.
I like that.
ANJALI KUMAR: If you people
steal this [BLEEP].
I'm suing.
GARANCE DORE: And [BLEEP]
your [BLEEP].
ANJALI KUMAR: I have a segment
idea for your show, for
"Pardon my French."
GARANCE DORE: Oh yeah?
ANJALI KUMAR: It's all
about para chic.
GARANCE DORE: Yeah.
ANJALI KUMAR: We can totally do
this interview in French,
because I took it in
seventh grade.
So I'm basically fluent.
GARANCE DORE: Yes, OK.
We can do that.
ANJALI KUMAR: So let me
just ask you a few
questions in French.
GARANCE DORE: OK.
ANJALI KUMAR: [SPEAKING FRENCH]?
GARANCE DORE: It doesn't
mean anything.
ANJALI KUMAR: I need my money
back from seventh grade.
OK.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]?
GARANCE DORE: [SPEAKING FRENCH].
ANJALI KUMAR: You
heard it here--
pigeons.
[LAUGHTER]
ANJALI KUMAR: It's all
about pigeons.
GARANCE DORE: [SPEAKING FRENCH].
ANJALI KUMAR: The pigeons?
GARANCE DORE: Uh huh.
ANJALI KUMAR: It's all
about pigeons.
GARANCE DORE: Exactly.
ANJALI KUMAR: I'm
still hungry.
GARANCE DORE: I'm stuffed.